yeah I would comment and it's our job to
name the elephant in the room do we know
what that is yeah it's a Freddy Krueger
in the room as you will I didn't know
that we have to bring our own maze and
rate whistles actors are the mom the
comedian is referring to is Harvey
Weinstein the movie mogul has been
accused of several counts of sexual
assault which he denies survivors I did
crowd and the tension escalates with a
member of the audience
[Music]
ah get out of here that's fine I am
happy to leave but nobody's gonna buy
anything Weinstein was here at the
downtime bar in New York and an event
for emerging talent an Barolo was one of
two women who approached his table in
frustration she says she simply couldn't
stay silent he is a symbol of the the
me2 movement and I think in general he
is a triggering symbol to a lot of
people who have dealt with sexual
assault and it's not fair to make them
face that in a statement the producers
spokesperson said Harvey Weinstein was
out with friends enjoying the music and
trying to find some solace in his life
that has been turned upside down this
scene was uncalled for downright rude
and an example of how to process today
is being squashed by the public trying
to take it away in the courtroom - he's
kept a relatively low profile recently
but in January you will be firmly in the
spotlight standing trial accused of rape
and sexual assault which he denies
Cordelia left Sky News Washington